hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast and keynote presentation
multiplex molecular panels at syndromic
infectious diseases testing presented by
dr. vera tesak an assistant professor of
pathology an assistant director of
clinical microbiology and immunology
laboratories at the University of
Chicago Medicine
I'm dr. Susie Valdes elaborate and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational women seminar presented by
lab roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I want to
remind everyone that today's event is
interactive encourage you to participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want during the
presentation just click on that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
and type those questions into the
drop-down box that appear on the screen
our speaker will respond to your
questions via email if you have any
trouble hearing or seeing the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box and let us know you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
on the top right corner of their
presentation window and follow the
process for obtaining your credits
without further ado let me join me in
welcoming our keynote presenter today
dr. I will now turn the presentation
over to her so you can see syndromic
turn off or not
and also they have pneumonia and
bacteria and virus also cemented in
space can be employed and also mono
flicks or smoke and
specie arts or fancy news
so for variable technology they
different between themselves in
complexity it comes down and turnaround
time the different differ between
ourselves with the number of targets are
from taken range from 14 to 27 and also
they kind of cover the most common
pathogens causing the respiratory
infections so influence a and B /
influence of RSV adenoviruses
coronaviruses comity Numa viruses and
among but here again wanna tussle and
mycoplasma no product alum so far
they've helped in many publications and
they have been compared one another and
also the laboratory development of fox
pcr assays in many studies and yes his
performances showed similar results for
most of the target if the differences
have been observed for adenovirus
influence of be influenced the p and
also human anatomy virus detection at
our institution we also are detected for
example two cases of respiratory
infection before the telegram he said
pika it was it for the assist on the
respiratory vinyl viral panel so it's
characteristics of is no panels as well
as recognized balance of individual
attributes you can even patient
population that will affect the
predictive value of air tests for
example in this case patients Direction
positive or birthday power Blanca septic
and that was confirmed by council but
slight false positive for pertussis on
respiratory viral bio panel so also at
our institution we also detected Teresa
to be also very detect enterovirus
sixty-eight outbreak in the summer and
fall of 2014 using this broad range
multiplex panels among other places is
very Mita rhinovirus and providers by
the memory in patients with respiratory
disease which was also
disproportionately affecting those
patients with asthma so regional
hospital level data from Israel you know
and who are Colorado through the
increases in respiratory unity 2014
compared to the same time to the
previous years this would do not have
impossible to detect that quickly
without the use of red fabric panels so
the use of these panels into early
initiation of appropriate therapy
reduction in use of antibiotics entire
implementation of isolation procedures
and health in syndromic surveillance by
public health authorities also that
fasting can also result in cost savings
to the healthcare system through
reduction in emergency department
boarding time and also decreased
duration of an antiviral therapy so in
this study by reform and other oddness
issue deposits of implanted by film
array was associated with significantly
lower odds ratios for admissions length
of stay and duration event the picture
of values and also number of best
radiographs in their patient population
for example in another study but browser
for children in particular they didn't
show that the use of these kind of
shortened hospitals a or less an
antibiotic consumption or overall cost
but they showed that it has proven
beneficial in civilian Monacan from
compromised patients and patients after
of them children
engage so in fatigue study that was done
at our institution
we found it improved on a long time of
respiratory consulate discontinuation of
empirical self tabular therapy among
patients found influenza negative also
another study by planted reported
shorter length stay and increased I'm a
total duration so these new novel panel
selected beloved epidemiology of foreign
affiliate varices to be perfect find
them in the past and also it is more
common during the influenza seasons and
recognize more and used to in the past
some things like also about the
pneumonia are commonly missed due to a
lack of impulse efficient or available
routine testing to laboratory in
conjunction with clinicians have to
define with age population will benefit
with broad panel detection at our
institution we use large panel for
immunocompromised patients in particular
there are otherwise healthy patients
with mild self-limited respiratory
infections emergency department or in
clinics around for smaller panels with
limited pathogen manual don't
utilization guidelines participation
populations for example children versus
adults also in the no competent
compromised patients and in patients
first the South patients are needed for
the proper use of these assays all these
measures measures will with limitation
of additional unnecessary testing and
passivity procedures they might feel did
not not reduction in cost so to switch
gears let's talk about leading cause of
illness impact in the developing world
because modern advances in public health
they all they all have led to decline
infectious area in our modern world
travelers or are associated with improv
is the best food in United States
before talks introducing actually here
calling because public show all patients
for the medical errors in institution
eight at the same local Desmond
unfortunately this restaurant was also
preparing huge quantities of food for
the Taste of Chicago outdoor festival
that was about to start a day later
that was July first two years ago so the
source of many cases rapidly intensified
and restaurant was lost does prevent in
the outbreaks from spreading further the
end of is Audrey there was total 69
confirmed 82 and 37 problems this is
where identified and cilantro are
implicated as most likely food weeds of
causing this outbreak
so this early action can help improve
bodkin contain the sound effect and also
faster the patient treatment and
outcomes so policies also did promote
vigilance within the laboratory that
used these panels will help to identify
unusual trance and to communicate it
very important to appropriate
institutions a surface Department of
Public Health and also the 1.42
component is 0.3% and also detect a
viral or parasitic pathogens in 137
cases with the mastic test is not a tall
order
so this allowed also increased
recognitions of HIV for infections
patients also receive targeted therapy
or where deescalate it sooner or where
the authoritative was not necessary also
positive to the toxin equally results
led to discontinuation of antimicrobials
in age of nine cases and therapy had
been initiated empirically with the
median time discontinuation was of eight
hours fall under so this kind of further
demonstrate
importance of these panels with our
eternal time that will affect clinical
decision making in pediatric population
done by study in document the patient's
presented
IDI identification was improved but did
not produce reduction subsequent
reduction in health care in countries
also in others
by Friedman identify testing and
accelerate reporting being compared to
financial my preferred method however
the impact of the panels and the
treatment and outcome is fully
understood at this time so further
studies are needed evaluate health
economic standard madness at all
recently haven't valued it clinically
but of false positive results we should
see positive results for Vibrio cholera
patients are not with risk factors and
even confirmed a Department of Public
Health
so laboratory in conjunction with
clinicians care to define which patient
population will benefit with these
brought an OD detection at our
institutions we haven't respected
ordering so it's up inclinations to make
our judgment based on symptoms or a
given data toward at his best since
bringing this panel we had increasing
cost but it's not performed all the
other tests used in the past serious
pool culture tool antigens tests and
also we stopped multiple standouts for
molecular detection for some viral
pathogens that we didn't have on our
menu and obviously because is that our
results are they are going within an
hour of receipt in the laboratory is
significantly improved our turnaround
time also technologies and all these
measures
limited testing and additional
diagnostic procedures so they might
contribute in ultimate reduction and
cost so to help providers for better
understand these results we also
introduced appended comments with all
the results so for example for
Clostridium difficile we not present
and could be asymptomatic areas also for
these equally different Ebola results
been also been comments that they are
present in both healthy controls 25.2
the national role of hospitalization
those are the data from 2011 and this
results in a nearly 1.5 million
discharges in that year from US
hospitals so also it founded for almost
seven percent of all Medicare cost in
2011 so the number of people dying from
Texas kids has almost doubled in the
past five years with incidents
approximate things are 750 thousand per
year in United States and all these
infections have 25 30 percent portal
area great delays implementing
antibiotics by more than one hour can
significantly increase the risk of
mortality early fluid resuscitation
combined with the initiation of
appropriate in microbial health improves
outcomes consequently approximately 20
percent 30 percent of patients with
severe sepsis receiving adequate and
intimate probl therapy on the other hand
with indiscriminate use of multiple
antibiotics they commit
some adverse events are also to increase
is it official infection and also they
can lead to a rise in antimicrobial
resistance so tiny diagnosis of
bloodstream infections is extremely
important this picture here shows the
routine laboratory methodology for the
identification of positive blood culture
after blood culture is drawn its central
laboratory and then after incubation
which can last from two hours to few
days battle likes positive and then
after that is pulled from the incubation
instrument and Gram stain is performed
clinician is notified than it takes for
just 24 additional hours for the
identification of 48 hours or longer for
susceptibility so this slide shows
misogynistic that are now available
after the noses of watching infection so
they can be broadly right for the ones
that perform derive detection on whole
blood and the others the FDA cleared our
market exposure panels that utilize
positive blood cultures for detection so
there are several commercially available
puts PCR blood pathogen also different
defend themselves bit complexity and
they also markers and our yeast you can
see them listed here at our institution
to be valued in to Platt went and
founded the correct identified Bettina
presence oma nobody really annoys
thank you identifications personally
shortened and those for identification
the routine microbiology techniques
today are also several studies that
showed clinical in fact one of them I
was a lot eaten by energy three cleaning
the trusted Liang's of patient
population B positive blood cultures one
the tail points provided and the other
the to drug molecule multiple panels
plus antimicrobial stewardship
intervention you can see that all three
groups are similar in size around 200
patients each study showed that panels
are first blood cultures in few hours is
opposed to the usual several days and
the pharmacist or a clinician who
provide an individual Sandra guidance
providers caring for the patient so
these are listed here are amazing
technologies for a molecular diagnostics
of services that are available for home
blood so there is no need for intubation
there is no need for blood cultures and
they're basically not dependent on
microbial growth but they're not yet
they've cleared the results can be
obtained only from four to ten hours in
the blood relatives this would be
significant improvement in detection
once they're available to either
laboratory for this advanced shortening
of course I'll stay and reduction in
health care cost clinical and economic
benefits for dentistry it only then
combined with a robust antimicrobial
stewardship program so courses are the
implementation with increased cost
increase busting increased labor and
increased numbers of into instrumented
and conventional my microbiology for
both action backwards identifications
the ability are still needed for the
pathogens that are not covered but it's
panels and also still for susceptibility
facility or clinical laboratory and
doesn't require our proficiency in
reading and first is done in real time
24 hours and reporting is obviously 24
hours so let's switch to many many
deities and encephalitis infections that
are associated with significant
morbidity and mortality as you can see
here they can be caused by different
viruses of curium 500 and so far there
is only one at the rear panel that
contains 14 targets with retinol and
there is one coming but it's not FDA
cleared so large study was done by labor
on almost 1,600 patients samples and
found for the results there was a point
for positivity and more than 99 point
I'm negative agreement between I mean
panel and conventional max every
sentence passed among them are false
positives very 40 for strep pneumo and
cryptical it's a caucus so account
institution we also found we also had
one positive for the caucus if the
commented and outer was negative so this
is another study done by draft this
small study conducted on pediatric
population and found a tentative
agreement the changed from fifty to
hundred percent the highest number of
false positive and false negative was
reported in this study for hsv-1
also some studies by Hamid found
bookcases that an A+ but culture
negative negative positive so our
results culture results and any final
results was actually focus pneumonia so
another case sorry
another case this is showing the Gram
stain gram stain was reported as
bacterial culture no growth and also
gram-negative okok C button M eternal
was negative but at least that helped us
rule out Neisseria meningitidis and also
from sequencing results it can be
confusing on the grunting so to
clinicians better understand we also
offended comments to these are available
for panel so for example this penalty
takes only eventually negative result to
no food other serious absolutely calling
the muscles employed this ammonia
preliminary results indicate that
disease if they're postponing I mean I
know interpreting conjecture with other
other results also for CME and other
viruses if there's positivity
preliminary results made exactly and are
reactivated viruses and also whenever we
have the focus neoformans are
automatically doctors sir older as
reflex experience with film or a budget
and you can see some of them here they
are not approved at the acquired for
diagnostic use in united states and this
is one of the panel that we used and
that was actually during the Ebola
outbreak because we were among hospitals
that helped us a lot as well during this
outbreak so what are some considerations
when all these panels are considered so
I will see right best for the right
patient at the right time so also if you
consider intimate problems you should
considerations we should worry about
writing their patient right
interpretation right and antimicrobial
and right thank you delivered so if it's
not delivered to appropriate condition
or pharmacist this will provide feedback
in actually change the patient therapy
sometimes if nobody acts on the results
they're just done in vain to conclusions
to bring all these panels they can show
some reduces everything specificity for
certain target compared to monopods
molecular acid but they obviously show
increased sensitivity it's efficient
compared to traditional laboratory tests
there is increased upfront cost and
they're still needs for some traditional
testability project because being gentle
speed up agnostics there is ability as
everything in only one specimen
and let's there's Lester Sandro from the
pages and we enjoy patient satisfaction
also the laboratories can increase
there's a better workflow and we also
have and ultimately complete reduction
of cost also previously Hart identified
and they're not thought from the
clinicians they could causing disease
and also are detecting more
polymicrobial infection which allows for
better games of surveillance and it
needs to fire a faster identification of
outbreaks and also it allows better
infection control so sometimes things to
consider would be just because you can't
necessarily integration of what is
technically feasible with what is
important this is according to dr.
Raymond Bartlett and you should still
adhere to these so all the workers for
the know is clean and fast effectiveness
prior to adoption promote production of
substantial amount of information and
considerable cost this will conclude by
presentation and I'm all confined
interested thank you thank you dr. tesak
for that informative presentation we
will now start the Q&A portion of the
webinar and we'll address some of the
most commonly asked questions by our
viewers if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your questions
into the box that appear on the screen
and click the send button our speaker
will follow up with your questions via
email so let's get started
our first question doctor tessick is
when did you Institute upended comments
for GI and emmy panel
so insecure name together when we
launched the testing so before we
brought us multiple talks with
clinicians all these comments were
actually product of mutual effort in
infection control and also at the end
like this is not 40 years that you're
using GI panel and any panel is helped a
lot because we didn't get many constants
in microbial plan thank you - fantastic
and the reduced sensitivity and
specificity of certain pathogens
described on the other we also stopped
order additional Isis but so far
especially they tend to do in our
pediatric population based on these
reports so for so far for voltages be
one and two we with this
and fasting in parallel we didn't have
any discrepancy so far so maybe we will
discourage it in the future okay dr.
tessick would you hate to provide the
viewers with any closing remarks I think
for example it's great to be a
microbiology nowadays because there are
many new technologies that are available
and I think use of these panelists made
available all these things that we did
never knew before all these new
infections all these new patterns that
are so prevalent in in the population
and this rapid turnaround time it's
something that's amazing the theory of
provide our results so much faster so
it's exciting to employ new technologies
whenever we can I think and then they're
proven useful in our patient population
absolutely again doctor testing for your
presentation and for your important
research I'd also like to thank lab
reach for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
remind everyone that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
third December 2018 you will receive an
email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event that's all for now and
thanks for joining us we hope to see you
again soon bye bye